all right and we are laughs welcome to
the last word with Laura Cognito any
Bartis hot hot hot by the fire you
already know this rowdy what we do
Lord eat boxes how are you doing sir
what is going on in the world of destiny
and how are you doing
Destiny's got this salad bar guy I
forget his name she's up there in the
top has called her and his burning lit
we've had some some thoughts about iron
banner have seen floating around in
Twitter some ups and downs so iron
banner has been going I haven't played
it that much played like enough to I
think get one one character done on
their quest I really haven't got a
chance to play much been goofing around
a little bit
my wife and I picked up Achilles rift so
we've actually and some beat saber if
you guys have not seen beat saber mm-hmm
vagabond Dulce sound anyone hear us yeah
hopefully we've been talking just be
talking no I guess audio anybody
neo metal just let us know if you guys
can hear us anyone hearing us
that would be much appreciated oh yeah
since that we go so far about it that's
what you think about it so you've that's
all you've been got a scared but we
appreciate it
ya know da CED event but yeah USA so
yeah I got that uh what is it beats a
yeah it's called beam saber so basically
it's like Dance Dance Revolution with
lightsabers that's the best way I can
describe it it's hilarious but it's fun
it gets to a point where it's
ridiculously hard so ok like we played
if you'd like once a month we played at
our friends house and then finally we
picked it up so I've been doing like
secret Destiny's blazing was just by
myself offline when I can sneak it as
much as I can it's in the incognito mode
yeah I've been incognito I've confession
and I'm saying just that my hours have
been really weird this week and I got a
lot of stuff going on and as much as I
wanted to play with anybody or anybody
like the little bit of time I had I
had to be efficient so it was like
selfish mode I gotta just do what I need
to do get this light up but yeah I got I
got banner complete I know we'll talk
about that and um yeah I got to set a
little question though am i plug in that
I I was on the impression maybe I'm
wrong that um you want you unlock it
that it will become part of your
ornaments I haven't seen that confirmed
I've only seen the ever verse stuff so
you would think yeah can it use like old
iron banner ornaments now again he's my
problem coming from two PC all that
stuff that I had on the Xbox account I
had all that stuff but the PC account
doesn't know about that PC account just
have literally what I've been doing
since last you know whatever November
whatever it was so only thing I have
like I don't have a lot of ornaments man
like a lot of classic gear that I know I
used to have like I don't have none of
the iron banister on the crucible stuff
I got like maybe one daunting thing and
which is kind of cool but not not too
much else so I was like damn I always be
cool if I could throw in those Ironman
assets you know this is just a rot and
the last thing I'll say is surprisingly
I am NOT a fan of the Warlocks I am bad
asset now that I got it
no oh try to put try to put different
shaders on it it's just how nomad
warlocks I gotta let me know I'm just
the vibe is not it like the Titans look
nice like the Warlock man I don't know
it's just it's not ugly it's just
generic I don't know what about you baby
I don't know I mean when it comes to all
of those I feel like they have that I
feel like they can accept shaders well
but I feel like I don't know if they're
gonna be they look more like a blank
canvas to me than something just like
yeah awesome and not white he's not the
set but I was like I'm just looking at
him again
mm-hmm I mean they're dark little dark
gray and light gray pretty much
everywhere I mean they were decent
ornamentation and texture zone like the
robes and the cloak and those aren't bad
the gold is a very minor in places so
depending on where the colors and shader
set you are talking about messing with
like dark gray and light gray so I mean
if the boy canvas doesn't want to take
it you're not gonna do a ton to it
you're not gonna do a ton to it and
that's the desi like his confession was
warlock fashion 101 like the day with me
is when I get a set like I have to get
the right shader and then I attributed
it to a specific subclass right so I'm
like all right let me see if I could put
so I need something for my voice I said
let me see try to throw some purple
shade is on it you know saying like it
just it just wasn't Rocky that I'm not
right well maybe you know it's not for
that maybe the voice stuff doesn't look
good for the shaders I try you know some
art colors blue some Froome in this blue
it's some are Milan glass whatever you
learn I'm saying and nah just it's like
it literally didn't matter what colors
are put on this I'm like this still look
like the basic generic thing again like
it didn't really transform it man
sort of hold on they coming at me and
Ric and Rico real what while that looks
the best Titan looks like you always
skipped arms day and never skip leg day
hunter looks big but that in a good way
I don't know man is something you know
what it is something about the helmet it
just looks very that that like you know
because when you put the shader on a
helmet the middle doesn't change so that
already pisses me off like you really
can't change the color of it yeah and
then the rest of it man it's just not
there with it y'all sorry warlocks I got
a thumbs down man not a fan not a fan
it's literally just right now I'm
looking at the stat rolls it might be
infusion material but we shall see I
have her stats have been rolling decent
on that though for some people like some
of the rolls have been decent and that's
one of the things we'll get to in a
little while but yeah we've done head
flake have you jumped into I'm guessing
no cuz that's not your first jump like
new difficulty Nightmare hunts what
level you up to now even what do you
have here like you know I mean an aphid
knife it is so nice you know exactly 950
with my artifact so I've been behind
actually I'm not late
962 just like cruising I am behind the
game so yeah I'm like now 54 like so I
did a couple of Nightmare hunts first of
all we are making a shout-out to
Scarah nine laughs after the last word
last week's last word please check it
out with the tremendous Karen and Lord
of all mother chickens was in the
building you know and um yeah man like
we had a fit you know he literally was
like yo you guys want to run it and I'm
like all right like we didn't have much
going on too much you had that
checkpoint which made it even easier
like you somehow came in with the
checkpoint because an activist I'll show
you the last showed you the last room
just so you can see I just wanted to see
it so once added got dogs on you let me
get that let's see it and then I'll just
sitting on it so we just like yo let's
just get it done and we got it done
y'all was like 45 minutes hour maybe you
know what's funny we kind of got
progressively worse with ideas are like
the first run we like half his health
and they're like yeah oh it's gonna be
easy
then we messed up a couple times then we
knocked it out but it's like that first
time was like shout out to scaring them
guys they had to have a look I was the
anchor or mites on my side you on your
site will you the anchor on your side
yeah I wasn't moon yes I was Anka on my
side he is my only thing
should we gonna talk real quickly guard
to salvation radio rates fantastic as an
anchor though I just wish where I was
messing up is when I shoot the Box to
tether yeah I just wished it was more of
a visual cue more of love it's just as
my nerd ball yeah like am I connected am
I not connected easy be yes like light
up or everything else in this thing
glows can it be a little brighter or
something just you know like hey don't
get near this thing it will tend to you
or you've turned it on don't shoot it
again or stuff like that I um maybe even
like how we have a status in the left
you don't tethered yeah there it'll
still tethered if you go oh it'll say
that word but it's just well that
doesn't change the box though yeah are
you a visual element by the Rope like
yeah so that right there but other than
that I think the only other messed up
I'm a once we got rolling was arm I was
good on my sock lap shooting but I like
the only thing I was messing up was I
didn't know I thought you had to wait
until we gonna call the Megatron as we
go
yes but of whatever the mind what is it
the sanctified mind whatever mind it is
yeah you know what it is consecrated
minor Saint Curtis consecrated what Li
thinks mega training is the heart beat
so signified I think is the end one yeah
so sanctified Megatron I thought we had
to wait until he goes up in the air to
DPS I didn't know you can literally
start firing and once you start off that
initial tether so I missed out on Matt
izanagi's DPS phase and I was like damn
I couldn't really did a little better so
improvement I'm gonna jump back in there
this week I will say I like the Rain Man
I like the Reno shout out I'm rocking a
template with pride I like that
I love that emblem a bunch of cool one
yeah no that's the one my warlock for
sure cuz I jumped on with you guys for
that that was fun right out to the show
that was a cool leg I did not expect
that he's like had a couple friends he's
like calling and texting people was like
dude we're making this and I was like
thank you so shoutouts is Caroline again
for one awesome to have him on it was
great chatting he's always hilarious in
a good time and then of course knocked
out the raid like in an hour after and
it was like perfect wasn't sure what
weekend was gonna hold and it was just
like Friday night we were there and I
was like just do it
this is joy and like in hours like we're
done really done and probably like an
hour in one minute later you had like
jacket shirt everything bro I do money a
discreet this grave I never had a rage
to be real to eat I know it's gonna
really sound fanboy in you know I never
thought I would get a red jacket I just
thought that would never be possible now
granted yet the rules have extended its
a week now and it's not like it is but
I'm just like you know what I just put
myself in the category that I love the
game I love to read I'm just not that
hard core enough cuz usually I just sit
and wait Aylin attic and sinister I let
them guys be the day one guys and yeah I
come back to me report to me teach me
the mechanics and then get in now I will
day one but usually you know you don't
you don't get too far so um yeah I will
say that I didn't think I'd ever get one
the fact that we got it done so quickly
yeah if I got my I can't wait man I got
to jack it ready goal don't hold your
breath
I think the I don't know if
shipped out like you know they take a
while
are you serious yeah you said the
scourge of the past I don't know I shot
nearest it was on here before he does
the infographic so if you guys haven't
seen him at em underscore in IR ass he's
always got great graphics I just like
him tweet out we're in the jackets I
don't know if he just got the jacket
okay what but like I just saw him tweet
out with it but I know like picture ones
haven't shipped yet stuff like that so
it takes a while yeah I think you're
right because I remember reading the
fine print it was kind of like won some
four to six week kind of kind of kind of
time no longer than L rolling so Wow
yeah a few months probably I wouldn't
hold your breath it's in memory
it'll be hopefully a video that you're
doing you're like oh yeah this if I had
to be that dude if the weather's will
just just a tad maybe I might show up at
ECX with it no I'm sorry June 28th
you're like yeah I guess my red jacket
on everybody's like are you hold on the
temperature went down from 8279 let me
get my jacket that's not even gonna hit
70 anything at night that's gonna be
nice
rodeo better know it though I gotta
floss with the edge
I gotta find an excuse to floss with the
jacket at G see I would it be that
Guardian tag T let's go oh well I want
ring on the jacket you're out of your
mind I might have you the jacket
eventually but I'm not gonna take it to
Guardian Conchas Florida in July Holy
Mother of No Jack is about a pool what a
pop no that's just a little base in my
suitcase hell no - funny vines gonna be
a fudge ECX I can't wait you got to take
it's ready I just gotta get to take it I
got the watch cut already Hotel yeah I
got mine book too so I got the got the
hotel booked so that is was nice because
they had a point to where I was like
are we are we gonna be able to like get
this thing yeah cuz I checked at one
point it was like last Friday another
because after we did the raid stuff and
I checked and I was like Guardian con
check the hotel it was like Thursday
Friday Saturday Sunday were available
Monday wasn't and then Tuesday Wednesday
I was like how was this one day not so I
was like I tweeted it I was like is he
thinking about somebody's like hey you
can call him I didn't do it over the
weekend and then I just went to check on
Monday before I called BAM so I blocked
it themselves I was like thank you thank
you yeah I get out wait how's the blast
last year met tons of people and just
looking to have more fun it was now I
kind of know what to expect so we're
getting there the day early because it's
on Saturday and Sunday mm-hmm getting
there on Thursday pre pick up Friday
hang out do stuff chill like people
start getting there that day so you
might actually get to meet more people
than which will be cool so so wait a
minute it's it's no longer Friday and
Saturday Saturday and Sunday that was
why just based off of what I said I just
you you was like yo this world this
would days you do I like who I'm doing
this a days - yeah 2028 early did Dave
know the only thing I do I kind of like
the Friday Saturday Jay so Sunday I mean
it's really gonna be a day of actually
okay yeah so my wife and I'll get like
an extra day out there on the end so
shout out to the other halfs out there
so they better have specifically if you
do end up going with your other half to
Guardian con my wife loved it because
she was like I don't have to worry about
anything she just literally sat by the
pool red chilled she had like sushi one
night and she's like you you do your
stuff for these couple days it's cool
I'm going to not care about anything for
like three days and she loved it so he
boxing time that's a great point because
let me tell you how fellas if you bring
it off a half out there here's the deal
it is legit a resort there is tons of
things to do
and you just chilling have a fun is just
real cool so you don't even have to do
any of that convention hall stuff that's
all included as a part of this whole
facility list so much things to doing
like I said every just a beach person to
chill like you would never have to leave
there's always something to be a part of
what just relax and show that you can be
away from the madness so it is really
cool I advise everyone to at least go
one time gcx yes Carol cities might be
going so we should see it yeah it's only
getting bigger so should be cool
hopefully they have a little more
organization on lines and stuff but we
will see but yeah that's one of the
reasons I wanted to get out there
because like you can have picked up your
stuff the day before I had that morning
line and I was like huh yeah those are
off it's a mess yes is rough this rough
see what's going on in the world of
destiny main well this week as we said
we had iron banner kickoff it's our
first one of year three so Saladin is up
there his cauldron is burning hot and
he's got some bounties for us he's got a
quest for us or mmm it's not even like
called a quest I swear it has like a
different name but it is like you know
yeah yeah it's just kind of the journey
you go through for iron banner to unlock
the armor for your character and just to
get things rolling back one of the quest
steps had a bit of an issue so some of
the quest steps are pretty obvious looks
like you know capture points get kills
straightforward use these weapons okay
one of them wanted you to it said it
wanted you to get super kills the guy
con said grenade launcher kills but it
actually did submachine gun kills yes to
get like traction on it to actually make
progress on it and people were like I'm
sorry what and fallout had a great tweet
to follow that one I don't know if you
know he was just like so you want so oh
it's one of those tweets and it was just
like some iron some Lord of the Rings
character saying good job Harry like
make sure you cast it like cross three
different movies in one meme and it was
just like this it fits so perfectly Oh
like somebody missed up like three
different like sci-fi fantasy movies and
cross them all
and you're like no no but it's like
that's it that was how screwed up it was
it was like how was it far off but
somebody copied and pasted text and
didn't check the copy and didn't edit
things and I was like I'm sorry but yeah
it's kind of messed up because the last
two steps like one with some machines
and the other one was arm grenade
launchers but then if you use the sub
machine on a grenade launcher bunny was
it was counting towards you no I'm
saying the thing and I love I lucked out
because some guys didn't even well they
straight up that's literally what
happened like I had that and then I
think I was looking up because I was
researching about ornaments um about a
question I had about ornaments I want to
see if that was the case about the
Ironbound a Iron Man or a bounty and
someone was like yeah it's the person
who rolled articles like yeah it's
glitched and just keep state with
submachine kills and I'm not oh good
thing I read this cuz I would have been
banging my head against the wall trying
to get grenade launcher killed so yeah
yeah that's that's a bit bit of an
oversight on their part and there you go
it was Patrick Stewart so it was like
Star Trek and he said use the Force
Harry
Gandalf Wow Wow yeah shoutout to follow
that one just absolutely just that's
hilarious
he always makes me last man his his
videos burrow light I get three strong
laughs in the middle he is we got to get
them all he's absolutely hilarious and
so yeah the quest had a little bit of
that in it that was the major hiccup I
think most of the time it's been smooth
for everybody and then once you get
through the quest you're starting to you
you're able to turn in the tokens and
stuff and people are getting some things
from these tokens enhance enhanced mods
are dropping from iron banner so if you
spend some time at iron banner and you
get some saved up tokens like my 13 or
1400 I got I'm gonna be dropping a few
of them if I ever get chant time to
finish this quest so I don't know if I
have time this week and I have family
coming in but if I get a chance to
finish one of those drop those enhanced
mods now my only question is will it
give you advanced like only or is it
gonna be just like unlocking advanced if
you have the normal kind of the way the
nightmare I was about to say cuz brother
I
have not received any of this enhanced
love not one so I'm so I'm I guess yeah
probably working the way nightmare does
cuz I think I've got the three nightmare
hunt nightmare hunt months and then I
did one this week at like nine twenty
cuz not bad at nine twenty of another
nine fifty yet and I got one of the
enhanced nightmare perks mmm and then
I'm guessing as you jump up in
difficulty and then you have the other
ones completed then you'll get the
supreme perks which are like tier three
which is crazy that those even exist so
yeah probably something similar like I
don't know if it's like you need to have
all the mods to be able to get the
enhanced mods so if you don't have all
the tokens and packages to get then cuz
that's like one other thing I even made
a video just saying hey had a level of
whom's and thank everyone for watching
it it's been beneficial to people so
that's good but nice was just like in
leveling up its like some people's
videos like oh i leveled up to nine
twelve in like five minutes I'm like
yeah you might have if you played for a
while farmed materials had six thousand
tokens and stuff to turn in the person
who boots up new light isn't gonna do
that so that's not beneficial so exactly
but that's kind of the thing that is
interesting about this whole mod economy
is if you can turn in the packages you
can get a ton some people are farming up
and they can see how many they've got
mm-hm and then other people are like I
got my one Tokyo I got I got you know I
played three rounds of crucible I get
one more package I get a new mod yeah
like they get one and you're just
sitting there like click click click
click yep it's fine we gotta talk about
it cuz I'll be having I got a problem
with sounded bad
hey yo salad what's up without only that
give it a mods this is like six to eight
iobit what's up with this swarm of the
Raven family fan no you can't get one
bro I can't get one and did if I can't
get one with spike or you can't get one
I really get them and if I don't get
immediate definitely in guys might know
it is always something terrible and I'm
just like man I got this build I want to
run so bad when as iraq and voids
transit with spike or something right
yeah but aj an aggressive frame that's
the problem you need that aggressive
frame for
DPS but it's still a grenade launcher
with spike they're gonna hit pretty hard
[Music]
bungees we got a P o box just start
sending the money at some point it might
guess the slider more for some way yeah
man it's just
Lisi Lisi hopefully I get lucky I got a
little bit more Banat again in I got
most of the banners done most about he's
done so I've been I'm a rock him just
like I said been unlucky with thee
so the Mons you turn in the pinnacle
bounties yes how much of a jump did
those give you in gear scores
substantial do you know the number cuz
I'm actually I would say I would say
probably if I was Kyle's kind of
floating 940 e coming in and I'm getting
like not 50 drops 9 like I was it felt
like 4 to 5 points so ya know like this
year too that's why I was wondering I
was like tier 2 is for tier 3 is 5 I was
wondering if you were unsub 950 with
like say like say your gear scores 940
how much of a jump that peduncle year
drop would actually be because they know
at 950 it's like 951 which we'll talk
about in a minute but right right right
if they'll substantial I think yes I
would say it felt like maybe 6 plus you
know 5 6 plus it felt wrong yeah I was
like oh man I gotta go do some great
modules like this is I gotta put these
on now you know kind of thing so it's
been rockin yeah and I have been hearing
some of the stats that have been
dropping on the armor has been decent
for PC not amazing you're not amazing
I've heard some people have gotten some
decent ones but obviously it's rng so
raid that's he seemed he did not even be
the best so yeah yeah fact bender saying
I think pinnacle drops were around 6
plus when you were 933 okay cool good
didn't yeah that sounds about right but
no yep they felt very big very uh very
substantial so my actually made my video
this week for weekly reset and if you
are what I was saying it was like I'm
not close enough that it's probably
gonna matter especially my other
characters but if you were like say 9
forty-five and then you started this
week you could probably work on getting
those last five levels hold on to those
pinnacle bounties don't turn them in
because going from pinnacle 950 - 950
one have you heard about this pinnacle
journey yeah oh man okay so we gotta
talk about this this is let's get to it
let's get okay so if you guys don't know
soft cap 900 everything drop works up to
their powerful gear takes you from 909
50 that's anything that's as powerful
pinnacle apparently gives you a better
+6 either way when you get to 950 there
is a gear score cap of pinnacle gear
only that it's gonna take you to 960 but
from my understanding from what I've
heard from people so you have to be
fully 950 first yes and then every drop
that you get for a pinnacle gear is 951
until your entire gear score all of it
all night are all eight pieces is 951
then Oh 950 to start dropping sent us
two agrees he's in that granny said +1
+1
that's like d1 man that's kind of rough
that's vanilla what if orangey screws
you and somebody's like man these
pinnacles I got for energy weapons dude
yeah I wonder about that Bungie because
bro like oh my god the pinnacles doesn't
go along I'm Ben I just get nothing but
energy weapons bro shout-out to whoever
I think it was names somebody put it on
Twitter and we I replied to them you saw
me reply I mean all that she has but I
literally should have been 950 a long
time ago like I've been doing my drops I
stay you know how many times I loved
that maverick loose like I just stay
getting you know that that just at one
category and I'm like man I could use
some boots or manic use another weapon
just a really really wish you know I'm
saying it can um it's a little arse use
a little better at that point but if
you're saying +1 that's pretty scary
stuff man
yeah that's gonna be low as you only got
like okay so how many pinnacle drop see
you get four from this one which is I
don't even know when the next iron
banner is they haven't even told us on
schedule probably in late November
during the other
final offensive or something like that
yeah we might have one more maybe mm-hmm
we don't know so that's four from that
maybe four more but even that alone is
like plus plus that might be like one
carat that might be like 951 I'm looking
at my character right now and damn I
don't even realize I'm like now 55 okay
here's the thing I don't feel like I
felt that yet because let me ask you
this question because obviously we're
not artifacts core if you're not you're
over it I'm over it right because that's
the artifact pushing me yep so do
actually updated nicely recently to
basically say it'll say like nine forty
five plus ten yes so basically I'm nine
forty nine point six plus nine okay I
get okay so once I hit nine fifty years
or officially gear scored that's when
it's gonna slow down forgiven okay
because I'm like I'm not really
experienced in which I'm okay I got you
got you makes sense
continue but yeah you think about how
many drops you get you have the raid
which can be some I think I don't know
if those actually count as pinnacles or
if it's just like completing the raid on
the challenge of the counts and if
anybody can confirm out there let me
know but even if it is you have the 100k
nightfall mm-hmm you have the single
raid drop for sure mm-hmm
and then maybe you've got what one two
three four drops in the raid yeah so you
have batali six drops iron banner twice
mhm and you have to get eight eight
gears lots of ek8 gear slots ten times
ten times there's almost not enough
weeks and drops to do that to do that
yeah I grew and here's the question I
have for you being at they're making the
rate of pinnacle drop like I'm assuming
the other raids are not pinnacle jobs no
there are benefits to those but I'll get
to that in a minute
yeah but I'm wanted to start running the
other raids because I want scourge stuff
on one mods 2.0 else
indicate yeah you know me so um Wow like
yeah that's not enough there's not
enough sources mm-hmm
so I don't know if I honestly don't know
if like even the glads and stuff like
there's just enough places for them to
do it I mean they could no life the game
and they could go to you know season
rank who knows what but generally you're
talking about not enough time to get
there and even if it was a full season
two more weeks that's still like what if
you could squeak it in you would have to
literally do everything every week just
to get the 960 and then and this is like
your 10 week grind so we're getting
there like people are 950 that wasn't
that hard and then you turn around we
get a new season probably a new hard cap
I don't know if the soft cap will come
up mm-hm and then we'll just kind of
move on past your 950 and then it's like
is that do you feel like that's like
balanced or not so much hey don't feel
so yeah I mean it definitely um you know
I think this it's definitely slowing
down that hardcore ceiling I don't know
you know it is on one part I like that
there's a little it gets slower but not
that slow like to do a +1 that's that's
that that's rough you know so and then
again here's my thing like when banners
not around what are you supposed to do
just run the rating and what else run
the rave the nightfall and then it kind
of done it seems like right and then
you'd run a knife hole what's for that
one one yeah one care yeah there should
be at least you know three to four
sources yeah like a couple more two
sources is kind of rough I mean well I
mean what they say in is the Raiders
left for it might be even if it's like
every drop counts and the finishing
counts and the nightfall that might be
if you're generous at six mmm you so
literally they're force of God to
salvation
yeah I suppose on the raid for a
hardcore in but that's still like six
drops over ten weeks and 8th gear slots
you're still too short there's only a
couple iron banners like math noise
still doesn't sound like it's gonna add
up and and guess what for those who
don't like to rate and those who want to
play play
Phoebe there's no equivalent yeah you're
gonna be 951 if you're lucky just in
your nightfall once a week and you might
get there if you don't enter G weapon
every time it's gonna have to be
artifact like senator said you use your
artifact you just gonna be grinding
artifact to get past that's the only
that's the only play to balance it out
because yeah he said he's not 65 through
the artifact I'm a shooting above it
through the artifact so that's where the
artifact are just playing the game yeah
that's it that's the solution
I already you already figured out yeah
that day like okay you don't want to do
that you don't want to get to that super
high level plus artifact plus pinnacle
they just play the game regular do what
you want go and bounties all day get
your stuff and get your experience that
way ya know just kind of one of those
things that's like it's it's interesting
in theory I like the idea of the
pinnacle grind to a point but also it's
like it should be it almost sounds
unattainable for like except two or
three like two or three people because
orangey might screw half of you yeah I
mean and that's kind of a points where
like mm-hmm that's the part that kind of
sucks
I mean are Geel screws like and it's
time like there's different games we're
like world you're waiting for that one
final drop or the world I'm me like
another week and it was just and that is
how some of that stuff goes and it's
interesting they're kind of towing that
line right now if it's it is if it you
it's like you might not get to that high
high gear score it just flat-out might
not happen yeah my Amaya and I think
what they're gonna do to shut us up is
they're gonna say look that's why we in
created this this whole artifacting you
just played again how you want and you
will eventually get there and yeah
you're not gonna be as high as as the
glads and the guys that's doing them
raids but bling on stuff exactly you're
gonna be close at your own leisure I
guess I mean I in fairness to them I
kind of get it but I agree with you
there needs to be just a little bit more
pinnacle gear sources that that to me
would be nice just to have the raid I
feel I'll say anything one to two if
they only gave me one more okay fine
I'll accept it but if they gave me two
more think it's a nice happy place
you have the nightfall the raid and
whatever those two experiences are you
know and boom yeah
and then the seasonal artifact will
reset every will drop down to like 950
or 951 or 955 right jump up again with a
new artifact think about the artifact is
as you get to one of my plus ten I think
now mmm it's like a million experience
for that next level it's definitely
slowed yeah what slowed a little bit
definitely they pulled back on those
reins be like oh those bonus bonus
levels were nice next one's gonna take
you a minute to get to you though mmm
make sense I mean it's not like I will
say the season pass being consistent
literally I think it's a hundred caver
time or something like it's not bad yeah
that always feels good that consistent
basis like yes your bounties move that
bar a big chunk every time you turn in a
couple of I was good angle I yeah I've
come full circle season I go like two
confessions confess I was I was very boy
I'll look for it when that little ball
go up I will begin let's let's look at
this look at the packages of the day
yeah I got it I gotta take the hello
that way I do I was I wish I was
fighting hard but I was I was concerned
very skeptical which was it no cuz I
mean battle passes can go bad poorly
yeah battle pass you think for tonight
you think people shower and stuff you
know how I'm very you know coveting my
exotics I'm very protective
but I am NOT when net it's like whoa big
bunny what we get the day I get excited
I be some modules cause the BC was next
okay cool
sometimes I use your strategy I hold
like the boots and the things like that
I'm wait I'm gonna gonna pick you up
just wait I haven't picked up any my
stuff in a while he know how hard I was
a little bit you music man it takes a
man to admit when you're wrong sometimes
you know I guess I just had a zit
healthy skepticism it's okay have
healthy skepticism that's all we gotta
have a devil's advocate for these
arguments we got we got a two-man show
we got to balance it out exactly what
may bring forth the season ray
bring me more materials will upgrade
modules and more cause baby let's go
I will I do feel kind of sorry for the
free track though cuz after you get to
about Oh bro is bearing out there numb
streets after like a certain level I'm
like damn we didn't get nothing for like
four more level yeah it's pretty quiet
yeah yeah so I wish like I wish they
would just give them even just like
throw a few more for me to throw a few
more upgrade modules in there randomly
do some materials so I know they want
like when you get to the end I'm sure if
you buy the season pass now and you turn
it on you'd get all the old stuff but
dude yeah we're spread the love a little
bit up there cuz it's pretty stingy like
you're at 61 you get the whole ten ranks
is a free you get 63 and 68 you get to
ever verse ever verse in grams 2 to 1
every five levels and that's literally
all you're getting for the top rank for
the last like four or five levels you're
gonna get like 10 cosmetic engrams bro
just for that fix Alma alone I can't
wait all those ornaments eat I'm all
about one immense now I go a lot of got
me and I show up at Tess's doorstep
every what's going on no I got paid
yesterday let me see how much my
paycheck I can spare all right 50
percent here you go set up an autograft
50% going to your bank account you can
use those tokens at any point in time
you're gonna gain so as we've working
through the season pass as well yeah
what are you feeling about the like
bonus exp drops and stuff like that that
you're seeing and things like we didn't
know what all those word first now we
know there's like 20 HP and better
chances for drops in these places and
things like that and do you feel like do
you like everything in the season passes
or anything you change in there what are
your thoughts on just like as we've
gotten through a decent amount of the
ranks now so far been so good like I
really it just to me everything seems
again I'm just gonna speak from
my situation I ask you the same question
but for my situation everything seems
right on time right when I'm getting low
on Coors here comes some cause right
when I'm getting low on materials here
comes some materials especially upgrade
modules cuz now I'm starting you know
when you get to the 950 I'm starting to
burn them a little bit I'm starting to
make my bills whatever I think the one
that I like the most is the UM the one
that gives you it says like legendaries
will drop with more energy or something
like that in the thing and I really like
that one said at this time I'm not
wasting shards of wasting stuff to
always level up something that has a
good stack role so I like when you get
that legendary whatever affinity but
it's coming in at five energy or rip you
know I'm saying or whatever it is I like
that a lot
um yeah I mean there's nothing I can
sing it like just [ __ ] there's nothing
that I'm like ah you don't say what's
this you know kind of thing what about
you I mean I pretty much agree I mean
overall it seems not to like overdone I
mean I think that's the first season
pass I think they didn't break the game
with it so they may have been on the
conservative side of things and like
here's extra armor drops here's an
occasional a couple cores and shards and
materials like all in all they haven't
broken anything with it which is nice
the little bonuses of like hey this
stuff can drop here or you get better
chances at this I mean there's little
things they could add they're probably
worried about adding too much at this
point right like chances of exotics or
anything like that peopled be like oh
we'll break the game or something like
that so it's like they're probably got
to be really touchy on anything too
over-the-top but I'd say overall I think
I mean just the the bonus increases at
the higher levels of like in strikes get
a higher chance at said gear or in you
know gambit get higher chances at like
the seasonal gear things like that
mm-hmm
and I will say this too but you know
being that I was Lord skeptic before as
far as exotics um because I'm I told you
my main issue and I got to defend myself
was that if the exotic drop rates stay
at forsaken levels then I'm cool and in
my opinion it has I feel like that's why
another reason why I'm not really
complaining again because
exotics outside of the one they gave me
I can only count maybe I got one to drop
in a crucible got to in real-world
situations so you want to know how many
I've had how many paths iosys Vale skull
of dire hum Cara a fin aspect carne
Stein armlets Oh guitar artist these are
all at nine hundred so they've been this
season
Starfire protocol mmm
storm dancers we get the exotic from it
I got Luna faction boots mm-hmm I'm
looking through mostly armor I'm in
touch with her so mm-hmm
but you'd knife for running a lot I mean
you definitely might wear full running a
lot right no no nope Wow just random
drops blessed by child apparently I
don't know Gemma's panelists have been
stingy like I got the Cerberus one I
think ace and that's it so see I begin a
lot of catalyst dad I begin nice sir
roles but okay so here's the thing about
all of those even if I will say exotics
do seem to drop okay your old exotics in
your vault they all suck and yes soon as
we logged in I joked with you is like I
gotta go through and clean out the old
exotics cuz they have like 23 stats on
their trash so bad unless it's a viral
exotic but even though you just go pull
it out yeah you're right got trash it
yeah go pull it from collections at
least you'll have like 40 something's
that roll on even if it is there like
half strength you're like at least
there's 40 like the old exotics I had
one though there was like rolls of 0 to
1 they were so bad oh they were so bad
but now I will say most exotics that
have dropped for me tend to have a
pretty solid stat roll almost all of
them have about a 60 range on stats
almost every single one ok so I got like
61 did I put a mod on that one oh I'm
putting in elective on that once I guess
59 that one's probably - oh we have 58
5662
yeah so I've had some decent drops but
that is the big thing about like when
you look at the season past and you're
like hey there are 4 exotics out there
ok it's not a big deal because honestly
half of those might be duplicates they
might not
so you may get some stuff you're missing
or you're gonna get just another role on
something you've already got and it
could be a different affinity type it
can be a different stat role it could be
a better stat role it could be a better
stat role in a different slot of stats
like there's so many different roles
that you have potentially to work with
like one more exotic drops can like
alright let's see if it's any good like
you it's you I can take all that I could
have one every ten ranks and I still
probably would be mm-hmm okay with it
like that'd be a lot of exotics for like
new people but for somebody who's like
already just going for duplicate roles
anyway no you can take all you can get
and you still probably won't have half
the stuff you want which I'm a fan of
because at the end of the day he makes
every single drop have value you're
looking for how that meshes and
synergizes with your build
you know what statues were simply
looking for and shout out to the
recovery stat because I don't know if I
was paying not paying attention before
but I was doing some I was on his track
where I was going very high intellect
and resiliency kind of armour bills know
and I'm running around and I was like
running in the rate of it I'm like so
hard and I'm thinking that oh well my
resilience must be low well I need no
boss resist no my recovery stat was so
long that I would get smacked and I
would be bruised waiting to recover for
the line to go back up yeah Rocky I'm in
gambit prom and I'm like why am I
getting lashed like what is happening
that I'm not getting cuz I wasn't
getting my recovery back fast enough so
that's what I saw your recovery are
don't fall into the mistakes I was
making I was going as soon as I see them
high in election discipline combos I'm
like yeah I mean either high intellect
and resiliency I was getting too excited
and just ignoring that other stat on
every other piece of the armor and it
which is bad
so yeah shoutout to recovery y'all
definitely pay attention yeah don't go
slow no and it's important to yeah
i diced he got those secret destiny
amiibos I don't even know what you're
talking about
no dusty ones they can't having me
buzzing man man HAMP they say he stay
running that five level of cough I got
to get down with you Hampton man like I
was slacking that you it really makes a
difference I know is nothing work to
getting lashed and I have to hide behind
a box or a pillar for like a good minute
until this thing comes back yeah it's
last damage is hurting me yeah mmm-hmm
so what is like I see your build theory
has changed as you've gone through so
like in a like this is when you're like
hey I want stats I'm dying a lot this is
kind of change is that pretty much kind
of how it went down yeah I've died too
much I've been so what I'll do now is
whatever the stat out of those are my
three majors because I don't really I've
got too much into the grenade bills just
yet even though it won't definitely can
have some fry I got some void fun with
one but um what is it over power
overcharge when a the one that weakens
them yeah man impressive dark matter
something like that yeah it is one that
you put in the class item that it cost
six I think that's the one right it's
like a six cost and you put that in your
class item you throw that with the other
one that goes on your chest and you
doing you are hurting bosses you just oh
I feel like a voyeur innate on them and
just let it sit and then DPS its really
strong so I mean so but other than that
I guess my strategy right now is you
know whatever the piece is weak on
sometimes I will throw a specific class
thing on that a specific arm neutral
either whether it be recovery in her leg
you know whatever on that to build it up
so it's a little bit more stronger
overall again provided I look at the my
stats and look at what's the week or if
everything is in a place that I like
then I start getting really customized
like okay what do i synergize this wait
why do I wanted some reload or do I'll
put some scavenger perks here like what
do I do and it's all it's right now
everything's about my Izanami build I
got us
my rifle um the one that gives you
energy with cyber rifle kills and I got
that bad boy all right you were
wondering when that was gonna drop right
the super energy with sniper kills maybe
I was worried I was worried so I got one
knee dropping from just random world man
I'm gonna say doing I'm gonna say just
doing random moon stuff like we were
kind of worried those were like pinnacle
type stuff he just kind of got right so
yeah that was irregular I was definitely
not a pinnacle active at least I don't
recall it being a pinnacle activity then
I did that and so on yeah mavin I've
been just been rocking out what about
you like what builds have you been
putting together any any type of flows
you've been going with uh I mean mines
have been pretty standard stuff as I've
just been going through like all the
different activities kind of leveling
mostly there's a Hampton shout out to
you sir I've seen it flighting around on
Twitter the broken punchy punch build
for the Titans yes oh my god so art
punching is apparently so broken but the
artefact mods and everything in there
that one's crazy the one you're saying
the void grenade weakened like oh I
still want to get my Titan like bubble
weakened grenade build in there and then
also still just messing around with like
just a heavy ammo I still want to see
how that feels just to be like I need
some heavy half of my super II need some
heavy hashes Sufi way constantly just
blowing stuff up like I was good to pick
it but I got to do it I think I got to
do that for one of mine too just to mess
around or at least on one of my
characters so yeah a six-course it's a
six-course to know 6 or 7 it's pricey
yeah it's the whole almost a whole thing
yeah it's like you may look you're gonna
be living on that one no other bonus is
there you can put on like 9 or resist if
you choose to yeah I know
you know shout-out to the finishing do
you got the one that gives you the
little over shield I think I've got it I
don't think I've used it that one is
very effective because it actually lasts
for about a couple of seconds now I've
gotta be like very quick I would say
it's like I might be eight to ten
seconds yeah
if you got that one that finishes and
gives the arm the two I use is that one
health every once in a while but my main
baby is the UM the special ammo that's
mine
cuz God you need that izanagi race all
about Izanagi right down I got a - I got
real quick two confessions with where's
a dog man
you know shout-out to it was a good run
man it was it was a good run sleeper you
know how I feel about you you always
have a special place in my heart but I
don't moved on baby I don't know is the
catalyst man and I could run two heavies
I could throw my little outrageous
fortune which is not so I'm gonna waving
but we go through we gonna talk about
that and you know I told my reclosed I I
it's hard for me to break that law how
he that no doubt is so powerful but yeah
Izanagi man I can't use any other thing
you know I'm saying like it's just as
you have recluse - oh because that's
another like it's got yanked out of the
game right now it would be a completely
different game for us so many people
like if they're just like alright
everybody we're gonna have a week off or
a clue sorc looses got to take a
vacation you know it's coming I was like
at some point man see it's gone or
something that thing's gonna get like
just just cut somewhere just cutting
down weapons
that's who good e it is I mean I mean
listen I'm asking for nerve but baby it
is so yeah so crazy and it's like it's
one of those - yeah shoutouts a divinity
I've heard that thing's actually pretty
awesome so interesting I gotta try got
to get that put on yeah we're close I'm
just telling you know what we have in
this money well you know God I don't
have the policy you know nerf God power
play he calls himself lord commander
nerve yeah yeah
if he says it it has been decreed so
will just happen happening y'all y'all
better get it in now why I can cuz I'm
telling yo you know I had to retire
because of a close it's a sad day
escalation protocol shotgun
poor low liquor aisle it was you was my
man I never put you down but recluses
here baby
everybody who has it runs it and it's
one of those things again you've got to
have so you know we've had our time with
it they haven't been joke loose I
haven't mentioned one-eyed mask oh you
know that got at some point they're just
going in the dumpster in the back like
it's just not gonna be a thing so and at
some point it's coming so don't be
surprised that's all I gotta say is like
enjoy it while you got it have fun do do
when it comes we're all know we all know
it's coming so don't you know it's
coming
don't y'all mouth don't threaten a
bungie diverse are some people yeah calm
Congress last point I'll say about
Rekluse which really makes it just got
here it's probably the only weapon that
it is equally dominant in PvE and PvP oh
yeah it is dominant when man of all's
procs just for killing anything and even
without killing anything with Rekluse
the close regular is still solid it's
not terrible yeah so it's just yeah and
it's I got that loadout man is it now he
dad and then I'm just waiting for my
swarm you know his outrageous fortune
just hold it down and that's been it man
what about you what should load up and
looking like these days I mean it's
honestly still just kind of random stuff
so I haven't gotten to max I've been
running I do this like I like I played
my Titan a lot last season because I
wouldn't jumped on was that my da man
had been playing it more mmm this time I
switched over played my Titan some and
then as I try and go over to the next
character and then I get stuck in that
character him so I'm stuck on my warlock
oh okay hunters just like sorry dude
still 760 over there taking a taking Wow
Wow oh yeah he's really 750 he just
artifact bonus so well if you got $20
you can move it up I saw that dude that
was this week it poppin huh I was like
wait that was $20 to get traded nine
hundred and nine hundred is the easy
part to get the easy part of it but yeah
just kind of a little bit of everything
I got the new fusion rifle from
eris so the nude dream bait entitled
dream breaker how was it um I don't know
how it is for like mm-hmm
impact damage and PvP and stuff like
that but in sound I will say like they
continue to crush like the sounds in
this game when you go like black armory
like those weapons oh it like I love to
tars gays the way that thing sounds like
a 50 Cal Barrett sniper like you fire
that thing you're like crap what I just
fire low hammerheads just like do too
and it's just beast and then you turn
around and you get like arc logic the
new Auto rifle has its own distinct one
but this beautiful this fusion I feels
like it's like you hear every little
bolt like fire it sounds really cool
yeah so it's actually really unique and
now when I got recently just because the
what is it the nightmare hunt server to
just go run in there do it at like nine
twenty yielding I like some people were
saying like if you need an essence like
where do you get the essence they're
random but if the nightmare hunts are up
to match the name just go run away twice
and you're gonna get it you're gonna get
it yeah i peep that yeah man that that's
that's something man I mean you're right
the sounds just tremendous matches I
mean everything like I said I've been
ranting about
izanagi I just love the way it sounds
when you forget forget firing when you
pull it out it sounds like you're
shaving a sword you know I'm saying but
it's like she I'm like oh this is I got
my little droning on a minute man they
they killing oh yeah I need a nomination
yeah see me on Twitter I've been on Jeff
Keeley's I've been pulling up on Jeff
Keely in the Game Awards I'm gonna pull
out Nejad bunch of community this game
you could say which I went about it
destiny yeah I could say I don't like
destiny for the guys just one sound of
music bro
I won a nomination not the only one got
a win I want a nomination we have been
getting great tunes
see the cops are coming right on your
head on their way we begin great tune
from destiny and great sound effects
from Bungie for years for this game not
to have one nomination in sound is a
travesty others born here and I think
it's a lot of the destiny haters because
they don't like the game forget the game
listen to the music listen to the oh
come on
man it is not even a question that this
game should be nominated so I need y'all
to get on that when the Game Awards come
we got to get on Jeff playfully don't
attack too crazy be playful just be like
you need we need this to be this game
needs to be celebrated on that level
because it's its next level next level
stuff man
really and truly yeah I mean I can't
argue that I'm sitting there talking
about one gun and I fire it I was like
damn but then you like you pick up the
toaster or you pick up just so many
things are unique and cool and that is
one of the things while random roles it
may not be the best tray like oh this is
trash but if I go pickle up like random
I ain't seen D I know that seems like I
know how that's gonna sound and then I
can still picture in my head like my
first scathe lock that I got back in
light from destiny to like year one and
that like auto-rifle is like this thing
actually feels kind of like an earthy
auto-rifle like kind of natural like
yeah like so no still great still absent
goodbye think about when you shoot the
colleague the little throat is amazing
like they have the best sound man if it
like a shot to UM happen he said you
know you could argue the best skyboxes
as well no easy easy
I was looking for it's the new bow from
the raid that was like one of the drops
I got I got the new sniper by the way
also very cool I'm mission I that was
one of my rare drops but I got the bow
from the raid and that thing sounds like
a ninja bow it's like silenced bow it's
like it's so it's so quiet
that's dough that's dude yeah like some
I know some of them are like food but
this one just this one it almost has
like less it's almost like it's like
it's already liar it's really close for
the name in give me the name on it I
want that that's fine I like that
really mmm oh there we go it is called a
crude redemption it's just like it's
just the combat boat it's not the
fastest thing in the world but it just
it sounds cool and it's a compound
though so mmm I don't know it's just one
of those when I fired it was like again
just like Nate just completely distinct
sounds really cool so that one's that's
a shadow mr. ah he trying to get his
ramp Audi but is it not yeah I know a
couple of people on that step hey areas
when you oh you need the rare bounty for
that weapon yeah I need the catalyst so
whenever you run that catalyst I still
gotta go run the heroic menagerie and
get me up that's my favorite activity
let me know I'm date I gotta do that one
still I mean at least I finally finished
the what is it the chalice or whatever I
just did it like you weeks later than
everybody else did then nobody was gonna
I was like yep chalice done yeah dad you
already shot it was shot a throwing part
of it too right for lucky I can't
remember oh well I gotta get the
catalyst to drop right then you can't do
it you get it perfected but you're
talking about to get isn't on his quest
yeah shut up arms in there yep yeah it
lasting shout to everybody
um there's a little thing in a community
cuz I know we talk a lot on Izanagi
today um we got to get on Bungie with
the steps for getting it now cuz trying
to explain it to a new player that
didn't have black armory and now the arm
the forges rotate they're not like is
you literally like poor attic he has to
wait every day until he can get his a
little key mole until it resets yeah and
stuff like that now some parts I heard
are easier you know I'm saying like she
ate a hand you certain steps but it's a
little confusing for someone who's never
played black army who wants to get this
weapon and then there is a step where
he's at now where areas talk about when
you need to get a random or found
rebound and that's kind of tough because
it's just orangey so you know best
only the best way I know to get the rare
bounties is to literally try and turn in
as many bounties for her as you can so
save up as you can turn them all in
together like do play yes ten of them in
together as many as you can try and get
that one to drop that's the only thing
I've ever heard that seems to like help
other than the ones at the bottom count
the ones will you use the what you call
it like the other guns the modulus thing
the one the one more activity like yeah
I don't know let's do it I think it's
just like the daily and the weekly it's
just trying to get all of those done
just like turn them in together so you
can actually check that one so they
treat me like how they treated spider
bounty with Lord of wolves without the
RNG based on the pound drop yep mmm got
it got it got it got it
yeah [ __ ] a bond oh the forges rotate
daily so every time just go to earth
look in the lower left-hand corner and
it'll tell you what the forges of the
day at reset of ever very daily we said
yep confirm daily which is like which is
kind of interesting it's like I don't
have time to go play through on like a
new light character but just to be able
to explain that experience to somebody
that's like there are some things like
that that have completely changed and
people are like looking up these videos
and it's like we're sorry but it's like
I don't have a good way to explain it
because I'm not going through it fresh
like I don't have a way to know yeah
ready is lit right now there's so many
people who are I am so glad I did
Izanagi before them I was like he was
like you planned a lot before shadow key
remember he was like I thought I would
throw out what kind of taper off because
I knew in the back of my mind let me get
these weapons I didn't know they were
gonna do this but I just wanted to have
be ready and if man cuz the in the raid
is an aki so efficient man yes it's a
judgement our punch definitely online
final guy for sure yeah yeah that was
pretty cool mmm-hmm well I don't even
know what conversation topic plan we
ever had in the first place of this one
but it's been completely off yes yes
I've been rolling with like flashpoint
just goofy point today but yeah we've
got also shout out to the big show where
he is gonna be part of the Bungie
bounties so he's actually gonna be up in
I guess Seattle hanging out with them
playing stuff like that up there I'm
sure they'll be streaming when it
happens so October 19th so tomorrow
really you are 6 p.m. damn on ps4 that
one's gonna be Bungie bunny and I don't
know if it's like crucible or PE you
maybe doing both so he just made plain
till he's tired who knows and then if he
see says they'll be on deck for that one
later cuz I think the first one is Xbox
cuz they did with a fill and Peterson's
yeah fill in Pete so they played xbox
then you got big boy big show on ps4 and
then PC doesn't see what comes next
there yes sir and we do actually have
some changes coming good some updates
some things mm-hmm so patch two point
six point one will launch on the 29th so
that's about a week and a half guys so
not this coming reset but the next one
and basically they said trample and
everlasting flames have been obviously
outliers for PvP supers for a while and
they're bringing back in basically bring
them back in check less return energy on
super less number of kills that you can
get both in PvE and PvP PvE didn't get
knocked down quite as bad
Don Boyd got knocked down a little bit
more but I mean you could get 30 kills
with it which is kind of bonkers which
is kind of ridiculous when I'm buying I
mean it's still 21 still a lot if you're
like pretty precision with it tramples
you know 15 it's down to 14 but you're
talking it was 15 now it's down to 7 in
PvE so that's definitely gonna be
shorter the energy you get back is less
so these if you're just hopefully not
getting killed by the same super on two
sides of the map that's and then also
the ways that I mean especially like you
know Titans I play Titan decent amount
mm-hmm just dashing is gonna be more a
little more costly so you can't just
travel wishers and travel with your
shoulder charges those things are gonna
get you talking about peregrine I'm told
mugged of damn one-hit killed me lady no
there's no shoulder charge nerf until
you nerve some other stuff dude
you can kiss my butt until handheld
supernova but I will throw language in
here so don't make haha supernova pisses
me off more than anything cuz you can
kill me farther than I can charge that
is an ability service so is show you
charge you just run on a round of map
when you have to be running and you have
to be running I can't just like old art
running around of course you have to be
run gives me how difficult it is to run
an engine destiny Oh forgive me about
the effort and scale right around the
corner and be like yeah I get it one
time I got away from my visible to go
back yeah a little Amelie to come back
to you gotta wait for your grenade I got
away from my melee and by the way I wish
you may lay your with your cone of range
I gotta wait your cone like with the
melee the mass shoot is without their
melee can you still get the 1 kill what
happens it doesn't even activate if I
don't have my male ability up it's not
there ok I just run around and go call
twins right let's go pass we gonna call
this a pass from right now without dad
when waiting for that nerve yeah we
partied hard when I hit that nerve but
good to you yeah when Hanover gets
knocked down I'll be doing the same
thing Harry's up there's like a weapon
have you you oh my god it's the like oh
yeah I mean I could call me but it
happens I would say maybe once uh for me
it's like you know once every 10 matches
somebody dude I'm like alright good one
haha hit around corners like there's but
yeah you just sit there and wait and
you're like OOP bro nothing angers
meaning that tightness ape shotgun
incoming beelining and I know what he
wants to do like literally all he wants
to do so like one-eyed mask nerf the
hell out of it and I'm a Titan that's
fine that would fix a lot of that
obviously but shoulder charge yeah
that's kind of equated out by some other
things so ah don't worry world likes I'm
fighting a good fight for us hopefully
one by the way I've also done this
before shoulder Church I've missed
people with my shoulder shards so it's
not always perfect man
be acting like that thing is that Opie
but we gonna continue you and Fran can
chat it up that's the thing if you want
one class a lot yeah that's what it is
you know you you take the personality of
the class and that's just what it is
you've taken before that other kind of
taking the personality wall out so it
did those are the things that both perk
us you know they've know what it did win
it anything yeah and then the hunters
can all just go burn in hell a little
annoying roles man oh my god
little hunter man sweep sweep soup soup
soup shout out the Aires he hates
shoulder charge when I'm with you
brother
oh I can't stand it it is like the win
button it's the free will my god I'm
gonna look at you and run and kill you
cuz I'm just running moving on Aires is
a hunter main oh we just landed on to
say sorry
everybody's with this subclass lovely to
Jess it was like all I can say is
everybody's a little mad about
everything bungees probably doing okay
yeah but I will say this there are
outlets for sure but yeah it does feel
like it does take a lot I gotta get on
some sinister theory it does feel like
it takes a little longer for the Titan
to get his nerves we're looking at
one-eyed masks
we'll get all be honest that I don't I
will be honest Lake one-eyed mask has
been way too damn long and I'm tight and
I'm just like now I'm the dumb Titan who
doesn't use it that often
for whatever reason so like you actually
won't see me out there using it very
much but dude know that like for as bad
as it is by too many people in high
levels of PvP skills to say hey this be
broken yeah like a rock
I mean over what yeah they just know the
warping they're like there's a whole of
warlocks y'all out here puffin and
bluefin spikes no shut that down next
week I'm like then we'll do some editing
we'll bring you back up but like no
we're watching we're watching you Titans
but we'll come back we have a date we'll
think about it everybody else Oh hunters
you're doing this too much blade wash
get you out in the garage
oh there's I already do it too much it's
like I don't know if they're afraid to
turn it off I think they'd make people
happier if they turn it off even if it's
like a long time fix or it's like
connected to too many things or it
doesn't if they picked fix one thing and
so what if it's like if it's a deeper
fix than we want turn it off just like
turn it off and crucible or something
you have any idea like go ahead using PV
who cares like nobody does but like PvP
just turn it off like if it's a playlist
up can't go in you have one night mask
on you're like damn it's like like it's
true in the defense I think maybe
because the way what do way it works it
activates then it puts that little aura
maybe UI wise I'm just trying to be
defending it now it's like my health or
gin or something too many different
things like for them if they touch one
it's a they're gonna like if they mess
with it it like ruins your recovery and
then you're just like a toothpick
waiting to get blown over who knows but
yeah yeah so there's some hopefully it
shouldn't take that long
I don't think and I think they've known
it's been an issue for a while so
there's got to be some deeper issue and
I hate this is one of those points where
they're like let me tell you what's
happening it's like why just tell us
it's like we have our eye on it expected
change in a future update if you at
least said here in the table be like we
see this as an outlier we feel this is
not working as intended or is too strong
or blah blah blah whatever their eye is
at least say what you got going on and
be like hey we're doing a little bit
more checking we're feeling like it's a
say something yes anything at this point
how does hunters and warlocks would
appreciate this yeah spectral blades I
remember that too they got them quick
yeah I got a couple of the quality life
changes
Sentinel code
the protector our Millah armor of light
timer now correlates with a life of ward
of dawn which I don't know if that
actually makes it shorter
like if a ward of dawn goes away and you
get the buff and then you leave do you
get to keep it yes completely I don't
know if that's actually like a bug or
like this is quality of life but if it's
that's called a life in the wrong
direction that's that's lower quality of
life so I'm not sure if I'm reading that
right Night Stalker just a bug with
chattering strike and things like that
and then shoulder charge speaking of it
well no they fixed the bug with one-two
punch and shoulder charge like fight
basically people were one-shotting like
nightmare bosses yeah it was crazy so
that one is definitely gonna be taken
away if not now it's the patch that's
coming so mm-hmm
so now when it comes to before I get to
this stuff when it comes to iron banner
I saw on Twitter that they basically
said besides the whole like buggy quest
step which obviously they kind of they
just said there it's gonna autocomplete
which is nice so that was actually a
really cool thing on there and on the
other side you have two days of three
maps only cleaning maps and they didn't
announce that two people go on hey why
am I seeing just these two maps to
Memphis I'm seeing three but no more and
then two days later they're like oh we
just wanted to do a showcase of the new
map so you can see them live and now
they'll all be in there it's like why do
you think do you think they're like do
you think that was actually intentional
do you think that's like back in speaker
like hey let's go ahead and fix this now
because people seem to make that I got a
theory I think it was intentional I
think what happened was and this was
this is my theory I think Bungie was
feeling themselves I think they knew
that these two maps let's be real a
Twilight gap and what's the other one's
name the other classic oh I forget the
other one but you know the - that's
classic from do you want yeah right
those are below those worse weirdos
court right so widows court target so
Galle and they were so hiked to bring it
so they like you know let's probably a
limited edition thing the first week
it'll just do it they didn't tell
anybody but I'm gonna play I'm like damn
I'm gonna get any other map like I was
gonna I was getting annoyed I go for you
guys I are at the TT roll off
after about three times playing in it
and then I'm like can we get back to the
other Nazca some those maps are suited
for specific kind of weapons you know
I'm saying and you can't use every you
know certain certain loadouts
effectively so that was annoying and
then obviously you get the other one I
wouldn't think it's called fragment or
whatever which is okay you know kind of
thing but yeah my gut tells me that was
intentional they just forgot to say it
and now it looks funny because we were
like yo what is going on kind of thing
so how long did they say before they
remove it out of I think it's just like
two days or was like it's basically
probably done by now or if it's not done
it'll be done by like day Larry said it
was like they were doing it for
literally a couple of days I think okay
it's just one of those like why not just
say it in advance why not just go ahead
and say that hey by the way first two
days we're gonna be on these maps case
you haven't seen him that much we want
to definitely give you guys some time to
get a feel in case we want some feedback
on these let us know after these two
days then you know all maps normal maps
will be in the rotation mm-hmm shad the
bull try refreshing man hopefully twitch
a play what I see is he was going on
morning night like ya know they'd been
misbehaving on us man we don't get
mm-hmm but other than that I don't know
it's just kind of a weird thing it's
like they may have been doing it
intentionally just a little
communication so yeah I agree that was
definitely I miss dropping on the more
miscommunication yeah just a little
little heads up in people wouldn't be
like what's going on is it all weird
yeah mm-hmm so they gave us a little
patch no preview for two point six point
one again that's on the 29th they said
forsaken subclasses will display correct
super icons on the PDP HUD so now you'll
know you know if a PvP players running
Golden Gun or if they're actually
running play brush or spectral blades or
Nova ward or kale Street so you actually
have an idea up top mmm-hmm I mean that
helps especially for competitive stuff
play that's a kind of plan to be like
hey they're running this versus they're
running oh god they're running this late
yep you can plan ahead or at least know
what's coming so information is quite
even like just the subtlety of knowing
you know on a map when you seen you know
the warlock here it is you know Titans
there by their little icon I think no
information to me is always good so I
always make the little subtleties what
you like they fixed there I watched that
was I don't want to call it he did it
but I watched him do it on stream but it
was one of those they like hey I heard
about this bug and we're going what's
the bug and I'm literally talking to him
on their twitch stream and they're like
hey is this thing if you go into
reckoning as a warlock and you put in
one week mote you were getting an eye
level Titan gear so it's like not the
right character but if you were like
especially when people leveling up for
the raid - if you were play if you play
and I did this backwards so I couldn't
even take advantage of because I played
my Titan first and that's which is my
whirling I was like well I'm screwed so
it doesn't matter mm-hmm but if you were
like hey your highest character was your
warlock and if this still works you
might be able to do this before you know
until the patch comes out you go into
reckoning tier one put a weep mode in
you would get so even right now say your
warlock what's your Titan level not
existing cuz I haven't touched it what
you should you should actually do this I
should do it yeah so you should go in
reckoning tier one and you will get it
like 9:45 Titan armor Wow
about to do that like seriously do the
if you so sorry Bungie spread the word
so those of you that will listen your if
you're tight if your warlock sorry for
those of you who played other classes
trust me I'm screwed here too if your
warlock is a high level especially like
hey my warlocks like 940 my Titans like
890 because I'm touching him in going to
reckoning tier one week boat Oh play it
here one's easy so easy go back out and
pick up your Titan armor just start
sending over you get a full set that
characters now like nine nine forty and
you're like oh that's that speeds up all
so many powerful drops mmm so do that
now before it's fixed because along with
the same box changes we have a preview
of some other patch notes so that is
coming so warlocks if you guys play that
primary go get that Titan up go have
some Titan button for getting that Titan
gear so that one is broken but will be
fixed and we can have
the fix the bugs for loading times for
gear preview in spaceflight good thing
players should notice the character
models update more quickly nice one of
this applies with non SSD folk yeah I
don't know in a big SME crew up in here
so we just run with speed so yeah
fantastical course that grazed from 3 to
99 just that though are an upgrade
module is still limited aren't certain
things to live I'm like somebody explain
this to me go so we're talking about
Fantasmic horse those are the ones for
you to buy the essence those are the
black ones mm-hmm I am always stacked to
the max on phantasmal fragments I have
30 always some sitting in the most
master always sitting there I don't use
enough like I'm not trying to buy the
cores because I have a few cores that I
don't even use yeah I'm farming other
stuff like that rotation like if this
thing goes up to 999 then the phantasmal
fragments should be upgrade modules I'm
pretty sure limited at like 30 for
whatever reason I don't know what prisms
and stuff are limited to but I mean
they're always afraid of us like
hoarding stuff but like those limit no
ones get really annoying - I agree you
know what I have that issue it are you
having this issue infects offensive
coins
I'm can't pick up any more it's like all
your full already
oh yeah the purple triangles on the
ground not not those the ones do it um
yeah why don't you give that aura is
that my fader you may be right I didn't
realize vex mind components the purple
coins yeah like yeah I'm captain 100
they're like always cuz you have to go
by the gun like bounties from like right
from her and they're only ten like or
you know like I'm already good I got
everything
exactly it's like what am i and there's
nothing else to use them on yeah just
fine
that's a misstep and that's one of those
things I wish like they build I have I'm
looking at my inventory and there's so
many consumables like I know we have
ways to exchange planetary materials now
to some level in places okay that helps
a little bit but we have so many
currencies that we can't really use that
much of like
I have a hundred hundred eleven black
armory schematics Wow Wow I mean finally
barian bow is actually coming through
spiders exchange thank good yeah and you
can buy light upgrade modules every so
often yes like yeah is it for something
but we have so many currencies and
things we need to be able to like choose
the dismantle hold it down for sure hit
it yes okay 100 percent button but those
types of things my goodness like so many
currencies to a point where it's just
like I understand like we have the
spider currencies we have the ADA
currencies we have 380 currencies we
have the course we have the prisms
Planetary materials tokens and now we
have like these vex components they're
gonna go away at the end of the season
but I'm capped at them so I can't how
why would you put a cap on something
that's gonna be seasonal anyway it's
gonna go away yeah they're so concerned
with them you know we were just hoarding
us hoarding stuff then it's like all
right I get it
but yeah it's a bit much yeah so I'd
love just didn't like I mean they're
only doing it for the course I'm like
just bump some of this stuff up if it's
seasonal especially just let me horde it
cuz then guess what you lose an update
it's gonna get rid of it mm-hmm stay for
steam they added a couple functionality
things like add friend and invite from
your they have to be in your fireteam on
your friends playlist or like in your
clan but then you can just do slash
invite slash add friend it's like if
somebody jumps in your fireteam you can
add them as a friend without having to
like to jump out to steam go to the
steam overlay like bonuses like yeah
that's huge that's huge
they went through a full deep dive on
the art station oh my gosh like yo there
are so many pictures in there that are
just absolutely crazy like gaudium i
mean they have some really cool pictures
but go to each artist and look at each
of them you'll see like raid bosses and
moon like there's so much art in there
that is just amazing what's your like
even just growing through this top like
what are your top couple that you got
here cuz I love I love the eros one
because I like that whole storyline yeah
she's being tormented and I love the
expression that our face like you know
saying she's really going through it so
at one I mean to be about to sound
cliche II every single one of these like
not not not the what you call it one as
much
I guess maybe because it was two up
close the UM calluses little spaceship
joint you know I'm more of a sky you
know saying but you know Irish yeah yeah
the golden buzz you're gonna say it's
cool but um just a skybox well the
weapon ones up close to one with the
hand cannon nope ridiculous detail
insane you know I'm saying but I always
loved the skybox one especially that
Mark Thompson one like that's the one
when you're literally getting on you
know the darkness ship and it's like yo
I remember yeah it puts you in a place
man like these are these are really
really good about you
yeah those that show the pyramid ship
both of those are legit I love seeing
the detail on the bosses too like
roderick wise you can see yes a detail
on both of the bosses so you got the
sanctified mind the consecrated mind you
get the detail on those witches
mmm-hmm freakin awesome so like you can
see like he did a lot of it nightmares
as well like skolas he went through and
did probably updated every nightmare
he's got some penalties pictures out
there like they're just awesome to see
like the detail on the bosses the like
different angles of them cuz I mean in a
boss fight or in some of these places we
like we pass through the story really
quickly or we get to see the bosses he's
like running over to take a poop or
whatever it's like I mean you get to see
all these quick moments but when you
just get to inspect the detail on some
of these guys like the main big boy boss
mmm sanctified you know Megatron yeah
yeah Megatron the detail like on his
face a little like vixx particles coming
out in the effects from him and like his
giant toy gun and it's just yeah dude oh
my god sake I mean you can't say enough
about you know the art team you can't
say enough about the skybox but then
when you see this work from other
artists it's like yo you know big
Heidi's dudes right yes they're like
like right now like oh man this is this
is really
I really like beautiful stuff absolutely
spectacular yeah so go browse all of
those gander at it make a new wallpaper
from two or three of them if you want
there's mm-hm
there's some gorgeous art out there they
got the new PDP map they've got the vex
invasion looking portal like that thing
I will say and I had my like doubts ish
on like yes the moon public events you
know and then the Vexin Beijing my only
worry is when the VEX invasion goes away
then moon's gonna be back to normal I'm
like oh I said you say yeah that's you
it's like it looks so the soul cool when
you see it in the sky it's like no hole
it's like half the screen when you're
under it it's mad yes
and then you lookin up and it's in a
black card and it's just that is really
aesthetically done well like you know
when them joints are coming in and you
spend the time to appreciate it
it looks really good mm-hmm indie and
then I'm just trying to scroll through
the rest like the one of Ariana's Val
with the other ornament on it did you
get at the end of the season that one's
literally fire so now go browse the art
guys cuz again it is just lately so good
so good mmm-hmm
and then we got to Armour 2.0 uh-huh so
I mean general rundown they said they
want to give players freedom to
experiment builds give players the
ability to bounce mods and then just you
know not overly spam you with stuff in
the UI so I have some opinions on those
but I want you to go just those higher
level topics we don't have to read this
thing verbatim yeah but like first given
the player the freedom to experiment
builds while also requiring players to
make creative choices how are you
feeling an armor 2.0 just in that topic
like how you build choices how's your
experimenting how's your creative
limitations with the affinity and stuff
like what do you what do you think it's
so far because I want to break down
armor more yeah um I think the creative
choices part it's a catch-22 because one
part of me does love you know that
option of saying okay what do I need to
focus on what do I need to to change
with this armor piece to fit my play
style and I love being able to do that
in destiny like that that's a new feel
it makes me take my time to experiment
you know the flipside is that the
affinity system kind of forces the RNG
in your hand so you know now it's like
damn I wish you know I kind of knew what
goes where and you know we'll get into
that with the UI non-stop but for that
one part yes it's giving freedom yes
it's making destiny better um choices I
would say there's some fake limitations
that they like self-imposed limitations
or certain things and not that's where
I'll leave it and I don't know
necessarily how I feel but I do like the
fact that there's that the vibe they're
giving is that part is also going to be
evolving so where are you at with this
one portion yeah I mean part of it for
me is so the game players the freedom to
experiment with builds to a point so you
have some limitations and while so
requiring players to make creative
choices when putting those builds
together okay mm-hmm so you have your
affinity your arc solar and Boyd's
certain guns with certain things they
try to balance out and they get to this
a little later I'm gonna just touch on
it when they were talking about the
affinity specifically they're like hey
they want a different range of ammo
types so like special heavy and kinetic
they want different ranges close far
medium they want different thematic
slike you know to make sure each type
kind of matches like Solar has rockets
it also has ashes to assets so we're
talking about explosions machine guns
that's ever stuff so they've got the
ideas there I know this thing had to be
bounced around internally like mad yeah
I mean there was a lot of like
brainstorming and whiteboard work done
to this one to make sure it's like how's
it gonna feel where do we start and they
said this is armored 2.0 specifically
because like 2.1 2.2 2.3 there's gonna
be an evolution to this as you said it's
definitely it has to happen I think one
of my biggest things is when it comes to
the creative freedom mm-hmm we already
have
we have limitations when it comes to
stat roles so maybe your good stat rules
on void I'm not Ark and you're like well
I guess I got to wait so I got a maybe
mix up my playstyle mm-hmm then you're
like okay what mods work within that
thing that got the good stats so we're
two funnels down then on top of that hey
what does it take for me to get up to
level seven okay it's a little cores
four five six and seven it's enhancement
going but not everybody cement in those
I have more than those well be honest
and I'm still thinking for sure - yes
but eight nine and ten to really get
that creativity if I want to go heavy
ammo fun like heavy ammo finisher on a
class item and use those last three
little upgrade mods are brutal so now
it's like you got the prisms which could
take two and you're like do I really
want a prism on this one I mean I guess
the last item might be okay because
there's no stats on it by the way why
does the class item not have stats what
the hell yeah I don't know me I don't
that yeah I forgot about that good point
that's annoying to me like give me
something give me give me some cuz that
was class items they just don't like
what why you like 4 out of 5 like just
let me know and then they'd be worried
about stats breaking but honestly we're
gonna get there eventually anyway well
so we've got all that mmm so you have
got to be the right affinity so no one
got to be there in stats funnel two got
to be able to use the right mods that go
with your build
that's three mmm and then you got to
spend all this stuff to get actually to
be able to use the creative freedom so
our ability to get to where they want us
to it's not the easiest thing to get to
so there's a lot of steps to get through
there's a lot of hurdles to go over so
finally enjoy the freedom like if I just
had like three sets arc solar enjoyed
good stats and I had finally somehow
come across or tripped over all the
currencies from ridiculous like gaming
to have stuff at level tin then it could
be like alright swap here they're 500
points the thing are 500 glimmer thing
cool switch in here and there but to get
there is light is quite the jump it's a
lot I made you some good points you know
I think you know I think they know this
is fluid I think this is new territory
for them my main issue is kind of what
you
said but also I want to double down on
point cost like the energy bro
like like something targeting for smg's
and all it shouldn't be like five and
six energy bro like I'm not and I'm not
gonna use that I'm like I'm gonna use it
but I'm not gonna use that particular
one because it costs so much
cuz it's like killing flexibility and I
know the argument of all just level it
up it cost a lot too low that is a
supreme commitment too low something up
and who knows you get something in the
better stat role you know if you're not
getting those materials back from what I
know so some people might have said you
actually might get them back okay if
they do great all I'm saying waste the
economy on some of these mods it's a bit
out of whack like they are so careful
with trying to be balanced I get it you
know and it's like you know we're gonna
talk about what they intend to do in a
bit but it's just I guess right now
they're gonna they're gonna have to look
at the metrics and see what we as a
community are not using and I'm pretty
sure 6 points for a little targeting
joint is something that a lot of people
are gonna be like that on our hands
targeting or targeting but it was one of
those talk is one of those
jack-of-all-trades architects oh well
that's ok that's why but yeah yes what
they are do I know that's rough yeah
shout-out to what W Prescott he said I
like I feel it like the gameplay loop
when Alma to play on don't mix well
especially when bounties will dictate
your weapons at times and you can't have
armor sets to maximize your play I get
when you go in I think for me I've um
kind of got into this mode and we're
first like how you talk about the
funnels right now there's a great great
analogy my for my primary funnel is the
roll first like the stat roll that is my
primary thing because I'm like ok how do
I play am i my feelings for me I want to
be tough I want to have my super alot
grenades sometimes I'll sacrifice Benes
every
in a while so those are my focuses on
the bills that I'm running so that the
first if the stat rolls trap if it's
like strength 12 or you know mobility
something that I just personally don't
use right as much then that's getting
shorted or fuse
so that's the first funnel for me then
once it gets down to that now it becomes
the affinity right then I'm looking at
okay how many of these do I have
affinity wise in this category how many
ARMs do I have there have void how many
so I gotta make sure that even though
the stats are good right that it's a
different affinity because I don't want
to be having a whole bunch of oil arms
running around because I'm saying like I
want to have that write it up so like
okay he a shout out to discord in my
back now okay yeah so I'm basically I
don't want to be in a situation where
I'm having the same affinity I want to
have the flexible I want to have the
best roles for each affinity and then
when I have duplicate affinity I'm
charting it or infusing it so that's how
I'm playing and thus to Prescott's
questions his thing it can work but it's
just you have to be cognizant of what
you have because my whole thing is I
don't want to be in a situation which is
what Prescott is saying where it's like
damn I really want confusion you know
something-something scavenger right and
Tim I don't got the arms that it even
going you know I'm saying oh I don't
even got the affinity that it even going
or whatever never want to be in that
situation so that's how I've been
playing just to kind of counter that but
I still like it you know I'm saying but
I know why they're doing it I mean for
those who don't like it they are so
afraid of breaking this game with the
potential combinations if you could just
put everything on everywhere and let's
be real if you do that then what's the
chase right there's no more chase you're
gonna have everything you're just gonna
put it to where you want and be done so
I I get where the community wants and I
get with that one and it says fine
little thing all I'm saying is bring the
cost down on some things there are some
things that I'm like fam this should not
cost six or seven now heavy I feel you
heavy is important have you could break
the game you want it you want to do that
thing
with the with the artifact six or seven
on that one I get that but let's this
thing is breaking not breaking the game
prices down bro basic targeting stuff
like that Lake I agree that stuff should
be a little less scavengers by the way
the ammo finder or whatever mm-hmm okay
okay so when you get like the bonus
brick or whatever I guess yeah it only
gave me like one grenade by one break
yeah yeah yeah so you're getting extra
you're not getting extra bricks you're
getting like a bonus brick that's
worthless I was like wait a minute
that's not how that's supposed to work
they change that unless I change that
they change that my question to you is
this though I'm glad you brought that up
so is the finder and the scavenger in
the same thing in the same affinity I'm
trying to remember now honestly cuz see
I have mush let me into my situation I
have a machine-gun finder right so yeah
I've noticed it works I'll see those
bricks on the floor but it'll be like
you said one right my question is if you
if there's any way to house different
now they're different so different
affinity so then they want you to mix
the car oh I see what they doing well no
like okay Scout will be all void so you
can do okay so I mean each type is gonna
be a type so like I'm looking at shout
out by the way I'm gonna throw it in
chat probably description I know it's
gonna say oh it's the it's the site
looks like I got destiny sets calm
that's that's calm yeah that's the only
one I know now I'll be using that he
built this one they did say they are
going to be adding a collection into
with the patch like they just said they
couldn't didn't quite get the patch
get it in with Josh but they said a
collection will be coming so you know
all your mods and stuff like that and
you can look at them and I'm like thank
God
but right now destiny sets calm / mods
absolutely just shows everything you got
once you connect to Bungie so yeah it'll
show them all but you got ammo
scavengers ammo finders ammo reserves
loaders normal and enhanced dexterity
targeting unflinching nightmare need to
be specific stuff and all that fun so
those are all there oh they are there so
basically they SEP you're right so in my
case
I have machine gun ammo finder for the
arc affinity right and it is an arc
machine guns so basically I would have
to spend three and three and I have six
I would have to get the second one okay
yeah avenger' machine gun ammo find her
like you do know and know where they got
it okay fair enough fair enough
so it was like and this is Armour 2.0 as
we said this is the first time through
it's a lot to learn they don't want to
break the game obviously so they'll work
on and that's what these really said
they're gonna be bringing down some of
the costs of things they're gonna be
changing stuff up the broad categories
they're free there for you to get
started in case you don't have drops
it's for I mean we have to as we go
through returning packages we play a lot
we do this all the time we have a decent
map to pick from so we're getting to
these specialized things and all this
fun stuff the general people who are
just like hey I have armor 2.0 and I'm
new light those basic mods that they got
they're like oh okay I'll just use this
one throw it on here for scatter
projectiles and we're good and I'm just
gonna use it on all things like they're
not seeing some of the same deep details
that we are to a point right so again we
still I'm terrible at this I still have
to at some point go think of this from a
new light players perspective and say
hey what if I opened my mob slit and
there's like 30 of them down there and
they're like I don't know to pick and
that is one of the things that truly
said that they want to do is relieve
information overload pressure on the UI
and I was like for me I don't care I'm
gonna go search through and find what I
want so give me all the information you
can give me right but in turn from the
other side they're trying not to
overwhelm the newbies which I kinda get
but plenty of games have stats and
things like that and they made them all
icons and pictures I'm like it's not
that overwhelming you've got pages and
stuff like I think we'll be okay just
just get past that we're good I agree
but you know I guess they're gonna do
you know some hand-holding in that
regard and okay yeah I want all the
information I can get I mean you know
that's just that's just me know so they
did say coming with mod stacking in most
cases stacking identical mods will
provide diminishing returns on their
effectiveness so
two hand cannon loaders say if you don't
have enhanced will still give you the
one and a half times benefit so it
matches and some of that stuff they're
gonna be bringing in with like next
season and stuff like that so there are
more things they're gonna be putting in
next season with regards to changes so
you can do two hand cannon loaders so
you can double stack reserve mods the
basically they said the only things
you're not gonna be able to double stack
are things that aren't gonna make a
difference
fast ball traction but they actually
mentioned you'll be able to run two hand
cannon loaders to shopkin amo finders
and so forth so if you do want to
specialize they said next season that
they'll actually be working on that so
for you with where we're at right now
what changes would you like to see first
off is off the RIP IV I've been
complaining you I please tell me what
mod I just got yeah there's nothing
worse than in the middle of combat you
find out you get them on you didn't look
at the screen for a second you don't
know where it is what class it is what I
that did I literally spend ten minutes
going through every single armor you
know slot to find out what the hell I
got you know my leave is something cool
you like you where is this feels a kind
of things so that's number one arm the
question in reference to like what else
I liked about it was just was I missed
the first part of question it was on
besides besides they're just things I
don't like yeah just what would you
change about it right now is with the
system yeah it's a UI cost and people
are saying their activities give
specific activities give enhance one I
don't know I feel like maybe just my
orangey I just felt like I haven't seen
that and for me so I don't know I know I
know it for example like the nightfall
when you have the choices right they
should also include mods or you know
better mods or something in the the
director screen to say yo there's a
chance you can get it here that that's
that that's kind of what I'm at yeah I
mean just sources and stuff I think
collection with that hopefully saying
hey these are coming from sources hey
the supreme mods for nightmares come
from at least hero and up or legend is
gonna drop supreme and up so legends can
help you with like master so ideas of
sources would be good
enhanced perks obviously known about
those knowing what we're missing that's
all gonna be good they did say they're
gonna be putting a few other Brad broad
broad category marks in there for like
ammo finders and ammo scavengers so if
you're like mmm special or kinetic like
they're gonna put those generic mod
finders in there the problem is costing
more but and that's something if you're
like hey I can set up a build special no
matter what I switch to I'm good mm-hmm
that's something you can work with as
well it said they just didn't get those
in there but they should be coming also
next season so next season next patch
like NYX patches the collections which
is great
like the collections are in a week and a
half which is awesome
and the next season which we all think
is like December 10th is you know armor
2.1 yes good edition I just think that
they you know still tweet gonna go I
like that they're receptive to the
tweaking though I think that is really
cool you know and I'm saying so um it's
a journey they're finding their way but
I will say this ultimately overall I
feel it's a positive thing it's fun to
do builds and destiny I think that is
something we've been want in the long
term is it perfect no is it a long way
to go we still got ways to go but let's
be really we've complained that destiny
armor had no place and the fact that I
am me I know you have and I know you
know the fact that we're able to have
some level of customization some level
of you know playstyle and identity and
I'm seeing build videos that excite me
like I'm seeing guys like you all put
this together with this and that and you
just have it you know it's on its way
there any infancy stages of something
new we're gonna give them a little time
to work out the kinks and you know as
long as they continue to be receptive
like how they've been in this table I'm
I'm excited for and I think it's gonna
eventually get to where it needs to go
but what about Yui I mean kind of the
same I mean it is definitely a start you
can tell the fear of them
wanting to make sure things are more
costly as opposed to game breaking that
seems I think obvious on as you said the
cost of a mod for a generic mod being
like six or what happed like those
things do seem up high in the safety
like we're gonna be real cautious first
like you're gonna have to be kind of
picky before you can just like double
down fully break like mm we'll find ur
double double ammo scavenger double
reserves and all of a sudden you got
like 700 machine gun bullets and they're
like oh cool so they definitely have
wanted to watch things like that
and it's kind of obvious the collections
thing was kind of unfortunate but I'm
glad they're at least letting us know it
would have been nice even just like by
the way I mean for like the destiny
armor sets guy he did a good job it's
great to have it and in two weeks like
probably won't get used as much which is
a bummer I wish they would have been
like hey it will be coming to
collections this is one of those things
it's not that hard to say we didn't make
it into shadow keep we're working on it
it will there will be a collections you
know tab for months coming just so
people are like where the hell is this
cuz I heard like three different
podcasts talk about this same topic and
then they finally throw it in here like
three weeks later we're like we no
transparency boys transparency marry
yeah but all in all I mean the price of
some things we'll see how that kind of
the economy of your mod energy balances
out but the other side of it is like I
want to be able to earn these things
really the only place to earn nightmare
mods or the mods are nightmares mmm nice
Falls and I felt yeah and for the
ascendant shards it is only the 980
nightfall that is it really Wow
medicine shard is either gonna come from
the season pass which you get like four
right or farming that 980 nightfall Wow
Wow that is to get a shard yeah and
those are spective or your other option
is to run legend lonely farm enough
prisms but it takes if you want to know
I went through the economy last time if
you want to buy the prisms or the core
it's expensive like no other mmm so you
gotta go there they're like hey go play
those nightfalls oh yeah
that'll allow you oh yeah they got value
guys one complaint I had they there's
definitely value the Danes to be skipper
the nightfall is over cuz I used to
skipped last couple of seasons I was a
skip knife Falls that's over I gotta get
in there for Mars for these these chars
these prisms all this stuff man I gotta
get in there there's no and it's a
pinnacle reward source no I'm trying to
do it gotta do it but that I mean we'll
wait and see what the changes come to
this thing but overall I think it's
getting there
so start what it's getting in there
mmm-hmm begin to MMO territories which I
like yeah
so that's most of what we have for the
week guys I know this might have been a
shorter one sorry if the stream was
questionable but shoutouts a good audio
we're gonna try and get like legit audio
recordings up so hopefully that is
absolutely perfect this time other than
that you got anything else you want to
cover anything you got for the week
anything you're looking forward to I
know I got the Leviathan quest next the
Leviathans breadth quest next week
mm-hm for the calendar so we get a
couple things coming but what do you
anything you're looking forward to
anything you're waiting on yeah I mean
see the fronts and all that to see oh
you know obviously that what the
Leviathan quests how that's gonna start
but to be honest I got a weird request
like I've been since I'm on my 2.0 mode
I've been on some really wanting to get
2.0 raid stuff and armor that I had so
black harmony stuff I've been working
obviously getting my 2.0 black armory
stuff can't get a black army mod to drop
which is weird
I've run dragon what do you mean we're
like black no not the weapon mods the
black armory
armor mod those come from the raid right
that's what I was thinking okay that's
what you see you days Yeah right there
yeah those mods there were no mods that
drop in the forges so I got to do
scourge
yep scourge Evan I need to know the
Fallen mods were scourge
yeah so I think for me I'm actually
excited to do all the raids I want you
know that 2.0 stuff because some of that
I miss McAllister
I'm mr. live I didn't know what a look
of it a fire it is
um guess I'm doing that so I'm trying to
get my I want to run on the starvation
one more time when I start getting those
mods and getting um just more weapons
and work - what are you gonna work
towards divinity at all or yeah I gotta
work towards that - it's just me yeah
I haven't had as much time to play as
I'd like between yeah crazy work
schedule and doing other things and just
kind of balancing out lots of stuff I
haven't just like no life multiple
things like I've wanted to so no I mean
I want to go get like taken armaments
and hi varmints and go do the old raids
for those so I've got those leads
unlocked I've got divinity to work on
we're coming up with the Leviathans
breath next week yeah that's the new big
boy big boy boat Quest is coming so how
much more we got for your dungeon week
after 29th yeah my momma week after that
podcast I know what I'll be doing
yeah that's what I'm most excited for I
will be that will be streaming dying
doing the whole back a lot yes all I can
say is I don't know what level they're
gonna make that thing but my God if it's
980 that's gonna hurt Vasko heart I got
a leg I get that bonus low because even
if you're 950 and you're like that we
know that Pennell 4 grand slow so you're
like 950 - 950 3 like getting up to like
980 that's like 30 bonus power levels
that is people are finished in the
season pass in there at like plus 15
like it only gets longer to get to so
980 is like it's always just gonna be
harder than you so I'm honestly hoping
it's not if it's like 950 kind of okay
with that like pinnacle in like towards
in-game type stuff but man I hope it's
not 980 that's just gonna be that's
gonna be rough that's a bit much like I
understand you got master nightmare
hunts now if there's like I doubt they
do another difficulty for the dungeon
I'm hoping it's about 950 and I'll be
okay with that or 940 like the rate yeah
that would be I'll be cool if I hit it
be around that point
that's literally what I'm inside I might
try to get a couple regroups together
and get that stuff and mess around and
then just get my pinnacle stuff off the
way and just get ready yeah I'm about
the same old to be grinding most
everything they have family in town this
weekend so I'm gonna miss out on like
half of iron banner which sucks
ah so easy to to get a less stuffy so
easy and quick yeah the bounties weren't
that bad I heard people were just like
knocking about those like you got full
I just want to save the Bounty's at
least on a couple characters so if I do
get to that pinnacle just feel like
click click click clicking a couple 950
ones I'm not even worried about turning
them in right now but overall yeah I'm
just playing some iron banner working on
quite there's just there's a lot to do
with this game man like if you when you
log in you're like I want to hit every
powerful it's like you're gonna be in
there for a minute you're gonna be there
for a minute yeah yeah that's most of
what I got yeah so I probably won't be
doing much streamin or anything this
weekend guys I will be busy if I am
playing it's probably just like solo
quiet time while people are sleeping but
for me I think I think this is probably
one of the coolest places destiny has
been the portal being built by our core
is probably gonna have some weird
ramifications we will see what happens
with that yes but all in all I think we
are in a place where bunch is
controlling stuff they're talking to us
a lot we're getting our PG elements in
there stats are dropping mods are going
and it's gonna be an evolution of the
game and I think year 3 is probably
where I see the brightest light for this
game as of yet and it's been 5 years so
I don't think this sixth year that we're
starting out now is hopefully where I
see things even going better that's
where I'll leave it for now man I agree
right which I think we are on the right
path love it yeah so well that's pretty
much we're gonna wrap it up guys
umm hang tight if you guys are in here I
will send you guys over to another
stream but if you want to let them know
what you got going on I'm gonna go try
and find a very small streamer so we can
raid them so hang tight guys but let
them know what you got going this
weekend so yeah man you already know I
love a podcast shall return every Sunday
is the Lord's Day still at NFL friendly
season time 11 a.m. Eastern coz the
Lord's do not compete with football but
again another week of just the Lord's
Man I think the people miss when it's
just us not always the big guests all
the time so you catch the Lord filled
dominus himself crazy King the Mad King
that's a little cool another bad mummy
Lord Sovereign Lord at it you know
addict out there with his well topics is
these crazy perspectives passion as well
as law solving myself trying to bring
some balance in order to the realm so
check us out told all the latest gaming
topped on the
Podcast YouTube channel please check
that also king of the statues one boy
king he's got some amazing Marvel and DC
comic channel statues please check that
out again on my pocket channel and last
but not least Lords of gaming dotnet man
tremendous articles we got some great
writers we got Destiny's stuff up there
we got gaming stuff up there I got a
cool MPD article please check that out
put that out this morning and if you
want to know about the gaming industry
to help to the gaming industry please
check out what I just put out on NPD and
every Friday the best destiny podcast
goes down with yours truly the cheetah
and before we grab cuz he doesn't like
to do this I got it do it for oh I want
to salute my bro man because like I said
I met this gentleman at a gcx formerly
you know destiny con it's been a case
slash formerly Guardian con and you know
we're just talking off stream and I'm
just like man I remember you know when
he had two or three thousand subs and
that to me was impressive because I
watch his content I thought his content
was fantastic and we just hit it off
ever since but to see his most recent
accomplishment Oh 40,000 sobs I look at
the videos what billion or the wit up
like hey this guy's podcast did with
little old me neither he's not but all
jokes aside no II I'm so proud of you
bro I'm so proud of you I love your
journey I love what you're doing I love
the growth and I just watch it I smile
because again like I tweeted to you you
know I see what others didn't see and to
see you get the recognition that you
deserve keep going keep pushing man
you're inspiring a lot of people man we
love your work the Bob Ross destiny
doing that heart content making it
smooth calm delivery easy so the floor
is yours so for G man all right I can't
live up to that but I honestly can't
thank all of you enough for the support
it's been an amazing journey it's like
honestly during the podcast that he has
been awesome that people were being able
to meet just the people who even been
able to play with say hello to and just
like all of what this game has done it's
like I got a thank Bungie like for
making this game
this community and being like somehow
getting me magic together to make a game
that has a such a great like somebody
tweeted out and this is like I tweeted
mine somebody was like I don't know how
like the Destiny community on Twitter is
like the nicest community legs not toxic
I mean there's always gonna be a few bad
apples but well I'm more talking
thousands of hundreds of thousands of
people mostly all just cool positive and
fun people like this community is
freaking amazing on the best so it's
like my shoutouts are thanks to all you
guys for being amazing for saying hello
and videos when I literally say at the
end be like hey if you just want to come
below and say hello and they say hello
and I say hi back there little stuff is
like all the fun of like meeting people
that I've watched this content creators
be bigger and go shake their hands at
Guardian cons and meows and and having
guests on our podcast that have been
like people I've watched and chatting it
up and mixing it up with like you for I
mean that's we're coming up on two years
of this podcast that we were crazy to
start doing curse of Osiris Dorothy
passing up homemade business cards that
I printed at Guardian Connelly they got
a key to get a whole you that was
probably it's been awesome so I mean and
then shout out to you guys as well it's
like it's been really cool to hear iron
Lords podcast you guys do what you do
like being invited on there a couple
times it's always a whole area I swear
every time I'm on there it's three hours
though every time I guess it's like it's
a long point plus you guys think this
podcast gets long that well yeah it just
blows the doors off of it so no yes time
to kill you guys you got a long commute
you got a you got an earbud that you can
put yeah you that you guys will you guys
will keep us occupied for a while so now
thank you guys our Lord podcast awesome
everybody over there you guys are great
so it's a little brother thank you man
it's always a pleasure doing this with
you but I had to shout
it was really cool to see so yeah
pushing to the next tent down the next
one and we go we gonna keep pushing this
thing too as well man joy really enjoy
doing this cast with you yeah so thank
you all very much that's all I got
probably a quiet weekend for me on the
front unless I just like midnight video
recording v.i.c pop-up I'm probably
working on videos I shouldn't be working
on but I'm gonna try and sneak a couple
in even if it's just my thoughts on a
couple things on my channel this will go
up as soon as I can
my day is bonkers today so as soon as I
can get this up on all the channels and
audio it will get up there so forgive me
on the delay in time but we were doing a
little different formatting trying to
get better audio up for you guys so stay
tuned there as well because the audio
hopefully will be smoother for both the
video and we'll see how this goes so
yeah forgive me so little growing pains
on this one but hopefully it's a little
little better quality as we go forward
so thank you all very much that's all I
got for me you got go check out iron
Lords podcast and Sunday watch some
football I'll be quiet this weekend next
week Master Nightmare hunts new quests
and new stuff to do so for episode 78 78
I've been up there man mmm-hmm so
October 18th this is a bunt as the Lord
Cagney you know signing out for the day
I'm gonna send you guys over to keep it
classy class I love that name so we're
gonna go mainstream and for this episode
of it has been the last word